render all are you doing
rso apart rep doodle パティルアーレストリー
ndn スピーカーズ
irea pampered same びょんプレイセット名分
r japanese ar ブリーディングのライブチャープレイング救おう
バージョン resp キーン even be the voice
フォールディングリーディング seasar アーレ barbie ケープボディ
[音楽]
usp だあれ apa 准教授
ur barbie down to do so do do do ワーレイ
アーレスピングブログ
berberjin border キャンピングカーランプ4 a poor
ん
アディだー the main タイプ operand sore eyes to
do in プライド s to be meaning 4
polar use アウディんがぁれ
# bar チーズ& a バーンっ
カーブス a シズラー民4 you and your por ディップみゅに系
ミーンズを
render carus terese アーレフ3 d フィロ have the
voodoo bass ebod 版 win 4
カーブステーションミーティング4プロピア
usastar teion デューラー mba
me forever レミー for girls do do do ラーを得ぬ
ストーリー
sanbe burger 融通ん
this project ポーターレバー counter in japanese
zone
and love 女流二サンフリーアプローチングし
第9倍
こんにちは
私がシティが君と申します
ええ
毎週2回
このジャンルデー
その言葉の勉強についてリリーを作っています
この医療好きなら一つはいくお願いしますし私の私のチャネル好きなら
是非購読
してくださいと
共和党行きについて話したんです
え
なぜならば
元いくはもう多分
[音楽]
toeic の受験者がですね日本で世界的に一番多いんですよね
処理にも処理で結果がですね
この全世界でその
と意見の提出を受けている国の中で一番その
結果がですね低い方の国なんですよ
でいろんな理由があるんですよね多分実験受験者が多いというのが理由の一つだと思う
んですが
a
もう一つの原因はですね a そう
何ですかえ
日本のその英語教育の中でですね
楽しく
永作さん ne-yo 6
独唱というか読むとか
結局その
いわゆる意味のあるものを器具ような教育はないんですよね
だいたいつまらないその英語を勉強するためにそのわざわざ
勉強する人の為に作ったゾーン
シーリオですね内容歯科ええまあ読まないし行かないあるいはこういう場合が多いわけ
ですね
でそれではなくてその処理は始めの時にそれは必要かもしれませんけれども
できるだけ早く章意味のある内容
聞いたり読んだりしないとその
me
けくのよく読む能力読書能力は以上経つしないですね
そのけく読む能力がそれがどのどんな言葉でもですねそれ一番基本なんですよね
でそれが非常に初してあればえっとぉいくも問題ないし
そして
友情に跳ねするようにもなる可能性があるわけですね
まあそういう意味で今日はといくのですね色んな結果について
そういう報告書がありますのでそれを読みながらみなさんと
んまたちの意見を伸ばしたいと思います
じゃ
また
このビデオ終わったらまたちょっと結論
させていただきます
それじゃ
toeic の
a
2018年のその
受験者の
文政期の報告症について
一緒に見てみたいと思います
この方航空ショーのリンクもですね説明ボックスに残します彼がもっと詳しいことを
知りたいなら
まあ調べてみてください
え
一番受験地が多いのが愛情チークなんですよ
特に日本
とどもにとともに一番結果が得祝井地区はアジアなんですよ
しかしこれは
間によって2つの原因があると思うんですよ
一つは受験者が多いだけにそして特に日本のように
a
あんまり自分がその英語の能力があまり
主事がたくないの人でもですねええ
受験するわけですよディフェン者が非常に多いと
by にあって他の国ではですねもう少して回収中になってから受験をする
そういうパターンがあると思うんですよと同時に
a
じゃのう
北米度が友人やメーカー友人とか
南アメリカですね
アメリカーフィーチャーなんかですねええ
acer no
ヨロッパケイトの
その母国号
が
まあフランス語とかドイツ語とかあるわけですからそれがもちろんに英語にもっと聞か
んですよね
でアジアではですねええ
日本語化まあ韓国語中国語がですねえ
またカーン
言葉として離れてますから当然もを少し難しいということもあると思います
それからですねつぎはですね国別で見るとですね
一番まあ日本がにええまあ一番下から
何ですか6番名なんですよまあアイジアの他の地区もまあまあ低いわけですよ
それからですね
まあ一番多いのはですね21歳から25歳
それがまあほぼ40%なんですよね
それからあのに木6から参入とその2つのグループが半分以上ですよね
でまぁ女性が46%
お得がへ
54%
それからですねまぁ半分ぐらいがですね
あの大学生なんですよねまだ卒業してない大学生ですよ
それからですね
まあ
これ童友社脳なんですか選考っていうのはわりと
色々ありますけれどもあの園ジェニー例が8割と多いようですよね
それからまあ
学生さん
またね多いという
必要なことなんですよ
それからですねあのまあまあさ約トレイ
グラフラン3ロガーもっと
印象的だと思うんですよその年齢的に
まあ一番若い人たちが20歳未満の人が一番
まあ-1
だから学校でですねいくら勉強してもですねあまりいい結果でないと
あとはですね45歳以上の人たちが低いと
そして一番やはり却下が良いのは26歳から30歳
おそらく恋人たちがその
まあ3回も4回も遠い居のだして受けた
へ
そういうそのなぜか圭くん
の持って二つの結果かと思うんですよ
まあ21歳から25歳もそう悪くはないとその辺が真鉤やはり一番結果が良いと
力ですねまあ女性が
まあ男性よりのやいや
んじょりからですねうん
あのなんですから学院って言うんですかああ
まあ大学生それらの方が気母がいいと
しかし小学生なんかはですねあまり結果がまあそれでもそんなに悪くはないと思います
ああそれからですねやはりビジネス関係ですね
のその
先行ですか学校大学でビジネス関係先行してる人達の方が結果がいいとあるいは社会学
とか
まあリブルアーチと言いますか
人
に同意ますかね
社会学みたいなもんですよね
それからあの
これは非常に面白いと思いますよ
いわゆるん
サージュ病院ですかそのずです
何ですか
さらにマンのかねやはり低いんですよ
学生よりもあるいはパーク単位はよりもあるいは完全にショツ凝してる人たちよりも
あるいはまあ学生さんも含めてですね
だからサラリーマン白い会社で会社が葉お金払ってですねたぶんその
と行くと位の民のいろんなまあ教育雨天
受けてですねそれから問う教育受けてあぁ結果が一番良くないと
面白い系たでしょうねそして10秒別でに業界別でみるとやはり
外交官だとかサービス秒とか教育とかねそれのほうがええ
まぁ結果が良い
分隊さんとかねぇ
りょょくをよ方形とがそうゆうのほうがまあそれ
まあ業界別にですねそう言います面白くないと思いますよねあメディア関係当然まだ
わけですよ
え所してまー
教育よその会社の中でのですね教育とか経営者とか
園生
専門家の方がいいと
んですけれどもそれは
それが面白いですね10年以上ようですね英語を勉強してる人達の方がいい
だから勉強してる時間
がその結果二行あるとしかしそれは
へ
もちろんそうだろうとびっくりすることはないと思いますよね
でん
ドナーどんなそのスキルですから
教育の中でどんなスキルが一番その
どこに重点があったかということに対してはですね4つの正
ぴく読むお話しする100全部
重点を置きましたん
枯れたというのが一番結果がいいとまあそれは当然だと思うんですがそれは多分
それがどれくらいの時間英語を勉強したかっていいもう
まあ関係がありますだけども
6ないしの意見ではですねこれの方のこのリスティングとリーディングはですねその
内容がです何かというのがもう少し詳しいことを知りたいんですよ
もしそれが
そのがいわゆる勉強するための端ないような内容を聞いたり読んだりするんであれば
当然
あまり良くなるしかしもしもう
小説も読んだり
何ですか a
映画を見たり聞いたりそれの
もう十分理解できたとそういうような
日スティングとリーディングの能力があればそれが一つのさのスピーキングの基本だと
思うし
そして全てのスキルの基本でもあると思います
そしてどれだけ
その英語がですね
毎日のように使ってますかということに対してほぼがほぼ使ってませんと使われてない
という愛
当然その結果低い
しかし半分以上ですね英語が必要だという人たちのほうが
まぁ結果がよろしいそれも
当然だろうと
だから英語を使われている割合にですねうん
結果がよろしい
そういうは当然そうですよねだから教育いよりも
実際の生活の中で言葉を
使う
使われているというのが一番大切だと思います
そして実際にどんなスキルを使ってますか
まずは全部使ってますよというのがよろしい
その
あとそのまあ読んだに開いたりするがあっ
それよりもやや低いと
レッスンがスピンだけといういわゆるお話だけ聞いたり話したりするだけですねその
ビーディングラインよりも
強調したいのがですね bd がドライどこに緩いに毒本というのはですね
合意を増やすために非常に大切だからそういう仲ですね
本当に例えば300ページの本を世
本当に意味のある内容読まないといけない
ただ単に簡単な字の保育のためのそういう本の中でですね
短いの阿蘇の何か
ものを読むだけですねあんまり
良いことになる
そして
飛距離も面白いですよあの
自分の生活の理由ですねー
ん
英語がんちょっと問題になっているとコミュニケーションにおいてをを問題になって
ますかとほとんどないという人たちが
結果買いするとなぜかというと f 1枚使わないということだと思うんですよ
ほとんどないとかあーうすいません
まずこれほとんどそうだとだからまあ非常に英語勝ちクィアの一位じゃないちょいと
あれほとんどないというのはあるいは
自分に対してそのう何ですか要求が厳しくないかあるいは英語あまり使われてない
頻繁に問題になってますとかほとんどなってないとか
時々とがそれによって結果が嫌
違ってきますだから
まあ
[音楽]
終わりと流暢に話せる人のの中でもですね
全然ないとかほとんどないということがないんですよ
あの問題がでは第二に日本語で話ししてますよね今まぁ最近頬
長い間使ってませんけどもそれじゃあ問題が出てくれないとよらぬ
それがある
ちょっとわからなかったとか言いたいことは言わねぇいいえなかったとか
そりゃ時々出てくるんでしょ当然だからほとんどないということはないんですよ時々
だから時々問題下あるという人の方がいいと
結果その東駅の中の
その結果がいいというのも
薬剤師にとっては
思います
そしてその英語の
ぐ22トリキュラー自分
称してますかというのがやはり異常に長い間という人たちのほうが気楽か書いてほしい
それも別に
驚くものでもないですよね
で何のためにその英語の
投稿方々として例の奥に
いきましたがと目的がですね勉強のために行った人たちが一番
結果ガールほしい
パターン2両公社とかあるいは英語の勉強のために行った人たちのほうがいい
今素晴らしい低い
それからですね
何回ぐらいの
出産を受けましたねとやはり3階以上の方が桁いるし
それがどれくらい長いで語を勉強しているかということに人に対しても関連するし
そしてやはりだんだん園生
[音楽]
東いく受ける自信がついたということもあると思います
だからそれもショーですよねその会社でですね
そのプロモーションでですね出身するためにですねもっといいじゃ vc たいう人た
g の方がですね
あまり良くない第それはやはりサラリーマン
会社員ですねあんまり時間あるいはもうて0じゃないと言う
もう一曲のですね
のあるですか
インディ系主ですね話
あるいはその今は会社があの仕事を
まあそれはおそらく大部分がその大学を卒業した人たちがいま
解説して所仕事を探している人たちだと思うんですがそういう人たちが一番結果がいい
いうような理由なんですよじゃそういうことで興味のある方ですね
this きゅんボックスにリンクをの星ましたからもっと詳しいこと
どうぞご自由に
入ってください
というわけです
教育は日本の園生
社会の中で非常に大切です
皆さん
やると意気でいい結果
まああって欲しいわけですよね a それでですねあの
保育は主に聞く能力と読む能力ですね
読書する能力をその
測るんですよねそれをですねでしょそれ僕はいいと思います
なぜかというと
本当によくわかる聞いたらよくわかる
選んだ複雑な内容でも何でも読んだら分かる
それぐらいの今いえば受け身の
その仕切りがあればあと話
各それそれがのいわゆる青ティティのスキルがですね
非常に
はやく
そのでメロできるんですよだから
へ
メインのその何ですか重点はですねそれはその
ていくいわゆる菊名医療内容ですね
読む内容ですねそれが意味のあるをも広い
スキーな
非常に楽しい
ようなものに重点を置いて
つまらないその
なんですけど勉強する人もためにわざわざ作ったようなものじゃなくて自分でこの英語
まあその単語言葉でもいいんですけれども自分で
君なんですから発見して
銃剣をとってやれば遠い雲甘くなるし
英語能力も
どんどんどんどん上手になると思いますまあ私は長い間日本語を使ってませんので
いろんな
そのちょっと変まあにも使いまして申し訳ないんですそれじゃあ
さよなら
はい dare you do with me
amends r 4 t
プラ奪い東生洲 you do so she ライター
aci ずメインプレイスウェイボ提供意見 japanese ベビースター un
巻 p 4位
あ一応競ってもストリートみっけ
pp テープテスト stei 分
released to do
[音楽]
voodoo ポリープをプールあーうーた
ana sistere seafood you doing
バージョンん